okay so I should be starting any moment
now this is gonna be different
hopefully it goes smoothly playing a
match against grandmaster pepe cuenca
and i think he sent me a challenge
let me check to see if he's ready just
gonna send a message real quick anyway
for anyone just joining we're gonna play
a combination of rapid blitz and bullets
more about the format soon it's going to
be four games of ten-minute chests eight
games of three plus two and ten games of
one minute and looks like he's ready so
I should be live if anyone's watching
let me know if you're in the chats
Belgium novice I saw comments but I just
refreshed the chats okay I'm gonna
accept please work
did that work I think that worked I have
a provisional rating on the site okay
the game has begun we ever ready I was
not preparing this I was expecting e4
but I saw he plays everything so we'll
see what he chooses Catalan okay
I'm curious how much preparation he's
done I'm just gonna play what I usually
play the so called ray raphson variation
good sign that he's thinking or he
thought for a moment there a3 is a good
move now I have to remember what to play
it's been a while I know at some point I
should play b5 but do I play b5 first
you did my castle first maybe I Castle
first played b5 if 9595 unfortunately I
can't draw arrows so people will have to
know their coordinates I can also play
knight c6 first knight c6 b5 kind of
like this so I'm not blundering right b5
my g5 95 95 95 d4 96
if Knight c3 I think I have Queen b6 I
know it looks weird like this diagonal
seems very suspicious but I just want to
play Bishop e7 and utilize everything 93
is also a move but whenever the bonds
attacked I just have Queen b6 so b3
mathematic move material is equal so we
could trade I could play Bishop e7 i
could play Bishop e7 right away it's a
sub I'm not gonna be looking too much at
the subs but thanks for supporting takes
yeah I think I'll start with taking
expecting Queen takes on that I'll play
Bishop e7 then I just want some like
normal developments late night c6 or
Knight bt7 probably Knight bt7 next so
I'm not blocking the bishop my bishop
will at some point go to d5 and my
knight will come to b6
I may be pawn will come to a6 the
backward a pawn hopefully won't be too
much of an issue can probably start with
Queen b6 here at some point I would like
to put a rook on CAS the only open file
like the rooks belong on C and D AIDS
so III supporting D for considering 95 I
think I'll start with rook ACH it's not
really critical moment I wanted to be
spending too much time early on if light
doubles up on a file I always have a six
could throw in a six right away to over
defend the pawn yeah I just want to see
what he does just trying to play like
simple quick moves so bishop trade then
a six could be a weakness I probably
have to trade bishops and then I could
maybe play rook c6 forgot c8 the Knights
probably going to come to b3 at some
points throw an e5 at some point maybe
it takes an e5 it's interesting d5
I don't allow d5 I'm gonna take and play
rook c6 multi-purpose I want to play
rook FC eights I also want to defend the
a pawn I'm just a little bit concerned
about a knight coming to c4 plays King
g1 seems a little bit slow but logical
so I'll play rook c8
I mean we could just trade off all the
majors and draw but I feel like this is
gonna be a fights I both of us have
something to play for so he wants to
play night be three nights e5 I could
play Queen c7 and then do stuff Queen c7
attacks and Knights consider a 5v5 d5
doesn't look so preferable so Queen c7
what is he gonna do
nighty - Roxy - we trade everything he
has to play rook d1 and end and that
looks reasonable there's not too many
other options I'm calculating 92 rook
takes c1 um
92 rook c2 and then takes takes takes
takes I'm securing the Knights rook do
you want to have an active rook maybe I
can play rugby too in the end but yes
Queen b3 so things got a little bit
weird
ah he also has wait a minute
Brooksie two takes takes rook see when I
take takes I have neither fates
thankfully so let's go for this if I
didn't have an eye that fate I'd be
blundering because rook c1 can be a
problem so I do have the chat open but
I'm not going to be looking at the chat
much but people can talk amongst
themselves maybe I'll look at the chat
between games but okay there's not much
time to waste so Queen b3 some move
now that's a reasonable move we could
trade like if we take on c1 Queen b7
what else do I do complain 95 maybe or
even a 5 so know if light has immediate
threat b5 is interesting I don't want to
be spending so much time could play h5
or age 6 oh wait he does have a threat
of taking in rook c1 okay so I have to
be careful it could play Knight b6 maybe
that doesn't seem right
there's no increment either so I have to
move somewhat quickly so I think all I'm
just gonna play simple Queen b7 we're
gonna trade more white might have a
slight advantage with the structure but
it should be balanced get my knight to
be 6
maybe you got a Knight to d5 even the
fly plays Queen B - and still Knight b6
he has some squares I have some squares
people have some squares
not the most exciting game so far both
flood trying to play solid be the first
game of a long match he was managing his
time slightly better than me not sure
what the Knights doing on c3 Queen is
tied down to it unless he wants to play
94 I can they'd be for a while
feisty maybe queen c6 play a little bit
of pressure trying to provoke like a
five and then I get the d5 square I
should throw in each six or each five at
some points also considering Knight a
four at some points try and trade
Knights can outside passer and 94 is
interesting
really got a speeded-up I don't want to
get too low on time I was playing bullet
earlier and I'm not too fast with the
pre moving 94 immediately maybe h5 h6
even age six his king f1 is a sign okay
he's bringing the King to the center
play this it's a tricky move it's
imbalance in the position he might have
to take because otherwise I'm taking her
winning e4 he could play off three yeah
he might play off three here
wait no f3 just hangs a knight what am I
saying so he can't maybe he'll take and
play Queen d3 that I want to maneuver it
to be six with the night I put the Queen
on b5 you turn down a minute on the
clock
but don't mind my position that's a move
to forgot about that move I feel like I
should punish it somehow I don't see how
he forged offended so my knight doesn't
really do much on f6 I want a maneuver
to be six support a four maybe target c4
might be some tactical ideas Knight c5
some day like a 5v5 d5 Knight c5 ideas
or even a five takes and then Knight c5
even the nine game lights can generate
tactics f3 mmm
I really want to play a five that seems
wrong
b5 also interesting move doesn't seem to
be working quite the way I wanted to
to move quicker play Knight b6 that was
the original plan maybe night C for my
night started doing some work
he can't take interestingly enough I'm
threatening night b2 here night a b2 is
that the thread actually feels like a
threat like if he takes takes takes I
have night b2 with a fork the king the
king is going to be a target on d3 just
a matter of exploiting it and whites
under pressure but I'm under time
pressure
might be to king c2 or so when I could
take we trade I actually don't see like
a main threat plays Knight c3 well now
Knight B - he still has his King move
king c2 we trade hmm yeah I want to
destroy but I don't see the crushing
blow
so let's move back he still can't take
on c4 I'll probably put the Queen on d6
maybe generate some more ideas well
night b1
okay so now I have ideas of five or 95
if I want to improve on my throwing g5
so you look like 93 no 93 okay so I'm
threatening to take on D - maybe Wendy
for if he plays Knight a three so Queen
c2 let's tickle the Queen ah but then he
takes no he can't take he takes I take
back with pawn and I win the Queen if
Queen moves where's my tactic really
where's my tactic maybe e5
95 I'm calculating Queen b3 and looking
for tactics Queen B through yeah I want
to play a five a five takes takes King
takes I move back
moves forward I move up it's not what I
wanted
Queen c3 I don't want to draw though
maybe e5 okay I'm taking a risk playing
e5 if d5 I then play Knight a4 so I want
to get a five in somehow
whoa it's unexpected takes takes I think
I'm winning the b-pawn just take this
I'm up a pawn I have two passers on the
Queen side he has one check I play King
h7 sweet does that still have to be
careful maybe a five relatively defended
95 I can just take it I want him to play
e5 so I can take the knight and play 95
but it's going to be a time scramble
he's thinking I'm up on time finally
like I have the clear plan a4 a3 a2
maybe in Queen some night a for ideas
okay that's a move I want to play 90 but
then 95 I guess okay let's play for G
fort Wow
pot is rolling let's take it's
interesting idea
a to
so 984 I've Queen f8 ideas - very
dangerous to get the low a minute
okay let's fill in this check these has
a 97 ideas a little bit concerning let's
throw in another check and probably a -
I don't see how I'm getting mated I
can't Queen immediately if f4 I made
into oh that's dangerous it's check I
need to sack the Queen for the Knights
check you might draw actually yeah I'm I
want to risk the time situation so it
ended in a draw wow I don't know if I'm
winning in the final position cuz Queen
g8 some made threats
Wow so how do I accept another challenge
oh I accepts I guess a good game let me
change the score 0.5 to 0.5
it's intense except clicking accept okay
I'm white let's play d4 I'm gonna play a
London I play them once before over the
board and st. Louis we have to remember
move order think 92 first I remember
playing yeah we played one of the main
lines
I played Bishop b5 I think he played
Bishop e7 in this position yeah he
played Bishop e7 so I did a little bit
of preparation beforehand and I was
preparing this h3 move in st. Louis I
think I played Bishop d3 so Queen b6 a4
still prep prepare this a couple hours
ago
I think h3 is a a side line within a
side line
the idea is I'm waiting for him to play
a six and then I'll take on c6 and then
get the e5 square and there's some lines
where like b2 is poisonous for example
okay so he takes first I think I should
take with the C pawn
I guess I can't really give an example
this changes the position but maybe even
in this position so I take and then I
castle
we still somehow transposed into CREP
thanks for the sub combo see appreciate
it's a five normal-looking move wants to
play Bishop a six go probably play Queen
c2 and rook F c1 now he might play c5
immediately then I have to figure out
what to do I mean I could take play rook
F c1 and I'm getting major pieces to the
C file before black not a bad thing why
be pawns a little bit backwards
I'd be three or order p1 if necessary
but he can't play rook e8
because my London bishop so I think I
have to take I know on to allow c4 and
then I'll play or a c1 and rook F c1
or night be three even might be three
94-95 s idea
there should be five also an idea I'm
gonna start with this see where the
bishop wants to go and then Bishop III
probably so I've like Queen c7 or Bishop
c7 there's moves here problem is rook c8
it will come eventually could maybe play
e4 know if it makes sense to open the
position
have 94 ideas
okay I don't think I'll start with might
be three I'm looking at Bishop a6 Queen
c6 and then try and like double up on
the C file I can play trade Queens I
don't think I'm better here if anything
black might have a slight edge the
bishop pair played the opening well my
e4 slightly unexpected thinking about
ninety five away at the bishops hits so
Bishop
maybe Bishop e5 in Bishop c7
let's start with Bishop e5
again he has about a minute edge on the
clock similar to last game but that's
okay still have time another sub mind
the mink thanks for subbing trying to
figure out bishop
okay so f6 f6 is interesting I want to
play Bishop d4 easy move but then Black
has a looming idea of a 5 so I have to
be careful I'm thinking about Knights e5
next like regardless of where the Queen
moves Knight c5 we trade stuff I lose be
- in the end though then I have rupee 1
in the end some counterplay 94 ideas
yeah let's go for it
I'm hitting the night so I think yes to
take I'm expecting him to take twice and
he might grab b2
oh but then I have rooks e b1 and the
queen would be trapped or it would it
Queen e2 it looks very risky for a black
it's a good situation because I'm making
him think maybe catch up on time
so takes takes I should mention there's
nothing on the line on this match like
we just basically agreed on the format
but there's no money or prizes at stake
but I'm just still trying to take it
seriously hence why I'm not really
paying too much attention to the chats
so I'm up on time you know see
considering moving the queen or maybe
he's considering what to take with I
think the whole idea of 94 + f6 was a
bit too slow
I think dish of a6 would have been
better for black who knows maybe I'll do
some analysis after the whole match is
finished
okay so we're trading I should be sad oh
wait the rooks hit so he has to move the
rook or take the bishop work out sevens
a move now I'm open minimum o'clock I
only get the knight to d4 and b5
potential up Oh square
okay so Bishop d7 looks playable queenie
7 runs into rook f7 he wants to play
rook c8 next so what to do Queen d6
maybe
Queen z6 is interesting it's hard to
remove the Queen and the bishops tie
down and the Queen's tie down kind of
like this smooth and I'm threatening
rook c7 I wish I could draw arrows this
is like an arrow worthy position because
the Queen's tied on to the bishop the
bishop side down to the pawn I have a
threaded rook c7 I have ideas of Knight
d4 hitting the pawn my e6 is a long term
weakness the bishop might move maybe I
mean Bishop e8 can't be played though to
remember the bishop side down to the
pawn so Rho K six is a move I forgot at
HUD can i play rook c7 still and we
trade Queens and then he has rook c8
I've Queen c7 as well even Queenie 7 but
then Queen e7 rook up seven Queens Yeats
and we repeats what to do Queen c7 oh
then he plays rook b6
so maybe I play like Queen and Queen I
for could be a move Queen g3 way truck
c7 takes takes rook c8 like 94 years it
might be five it's interesting I might
go for it
it does look a risky can also take on b2
I have to calculate man - okay - canteen
I don't think he can take on b2 I think
I'm gonna go for this idea of 94 95 it
feels wrong it could just be wrong okay
I'll have to go for it time was ticking
so there's a funny line Queen takes b2
Queen takes you seven Queen takes a one
check King eh - I'm threatening mates
and the only way to stop it is f5 but
that I have Knight d4 so I think that
refutes Queen takes me to otherwise I
mean I'm expecting rook takes c6 Rick
takes B 7 and then rook c8 after which
I'll play Knight d4 with idea of Knight
b5 also stopping Roxy - and time is
equalizing gonna be another time
scramble so there's two more games of
ten minutes chess after this it's a lot
of chess already getting tired
I'm staying up on time is actually a
very important factor what else could he
be thinking about like I don't think
anything else works I think he has to
take on d6 yeah thanks for the sub to Co
okay so going into this line things are
kind of tied down to each other I want
to play Knight d5 and if we trade the a
file opens for my rook and I get a past
be pawn so e5 only helps me do that
not sure how black on tangulls here
maybe move the bishop bishop c6 hi
Brooke b6 or Brooke a7 even to win the
pawn
'if i okay mean how does he defend in
the end it's gonna play Brooke AIDS but
then I have rook c1 and I get pigs on
the seventh this should be completely
winning I gave a lecture about this type
in pigs on the seventh into YouTube find
my st. Louis chess club video like that
rook is coming here maybe he'll play AI
v g6 and pray but now I'll just start
pushing my beep lon or he'll play d4
maybe Wow
please don't tell me this is gonna be
another draw this might be another draw
takes takes rook here d3 takes I start
checking maybe I come back in the end I
mean I think I have to go for this I
have to start with taking I think yeah
I'll start with taking and promise he
has like Brooks here Brooks he won in
the end
and if I got kind of play with my pawn I
mean okay I'm the only one playing for a
win though b6
I mean King f1 maybe King f1 d3 king e 1
D 2 O that loses okay so let's go for
this
take on g7 we'll see where he moves the
king so I have to calculate these lines
where the rook comes back and maybe my
King comes to f1 like it might actually
be okay
maybe I check and then play rook c7
promise he attacks wait I have ripped d7
as well
rook t7 wait a minute rook d7 g7 might
be winning or d7 plays rook to e8 we
trade everything and then I have King f1
that's winning
I think this is winning also I'm
threatening mate after it is so ripped
yet I just made them it sounds to me
winning I'm up two pawns wait I can't
count I'm up three pawns no I can't
count about two pawns I'm about to be up
three pawns cuz all in d3 you're so in
b5 it's hard to count number is that
will continually change no okay
so let's demonstrate some reasonable
technique rook a3 maybe I don't want to
wind up passive now let's check and come
behind you want to be as active as
possible I'll play G 3 H 4
and just keep my time advantage and
slowly steadily make progress at least
attempt to look here came here maybe
just this I keep pushing when we trade
pawns just make it easy oh I forgot
about that move but I have h7 now I can
check and come back I hold onto the H
pawn and i activate my king let's play
King f3 and King g4 probably that's
horror feels like there should be some
maid here
King h4 I want to steal me I want to
play g4 and f5
he takes it should be winning somehow I
5 and then probably I come win the pawn
like this move
there's no stale matrix you would love
to sack his rook but I've learned too
many lessons in the past
okay I want to gain so it is I'll just
update the score 1.5 to 0.5 this over
okay and how do I accept another
challenge canceled I don't know how to
challenge so I'm waiting on a challenge
okay he's sent a challenge so let's
accept okay so we have two more games of
10 plus 0 and then we have blitz good
luck
do I play I don't even know
wait I'm white again I should be black
again right I'm so confused
unless oh it like it's a random
challenge except there we go okay good
luck
efore okay so he's playing something
different than the first game it's 46
open Sicilian
yeah I was preparing this earlier some
played Bishop e2 but what was i
preparing I was preparing d6 I think d6
and then we trade I have to remember
Queen King Bishop d7 that I have a
novelty coming up
is he has one game in the database with
your KD one I was preparing Queen b6
hey it's bits thanks you got chess I
thought I turn the sound off for bits
but I guess not
yeah so you play rock 81 before and this
is where I played queen g6 now he's in
new territory
he played some player who played h5 and
it was a long fights I deal with Queen
b6 there's some some pressure on f2
there's some interesting line which I'm
trying to remember I think I Castle here
and then I play rook t1 or up - Yates to
my castle hey castle cuz I remember the
rook coming to f8 it's a very sharp
position like this will probably be the
most this is the most interesting
opening we've had so far first two games
were a little bit I don't know
positional this is opposites like a
sling imbalances in the structure yeah
b3 is a fine move Bishop t4 is an idea
to put the bishop on e5
I'll admit I didn't really prepare it
too much beyond this I think I'll play
Bishop d4 cuz why not I mean he might
play my day 4 we trade Bishop e5
hmm let's do it what just happened there
I didn't even scroll okay okay looks
okay I'm a little bit concerned about
putting my dish money 5 but maybe it's
okay Rudy 3 interesting I want to play
rook hg8 yeah let's play you're against
us there's a few ideas I might want to
play rough g5 followed by rook DG 891
wow it's fancy wants to play c3 maybe
eventually f4
there should be five should probably
hold off you rook g6 as a move you're up
g6 is very logical
g5 also logical
I'll start with rook g6 I didn't play
rook g5 because it might get hit with f4
later maybe at some point I want to just
play f5 and sack a pawn or just open up
my bishop both bishops c3 okay pretty
much have to do this now it's the
question is this bishop a strong piece
or is it a target because that four
could very easily trap my bishop but
that pawn is currently pinned worst-case
scenario I have that five create some
treating squares my trade Queens here
actually I have to trade Queens
otherwise I've run into f4 he's gonna
have Knight c4 which is actually quite
annoying but what else do I do I mean I
don't really have too many other options
there's some interesting idea to take
play Bishop b5 c4 bishop c6 f for Bishop
b2 and then walk around let's do it so I
don't think my bishops getting trapped
also I'll all up be attacking me for I
mean I'm expecting Knight takes
I mean what else can you do
rook takes it's all so I guess playable
okay he takes with Knights so if if the
pawn lands on c4 he doesn't have Knight
c4 and that opens up Bishop b2 now e4 is
attacked
so if he plays out for I could consider
it Bishop takes e4 but I also just have
the maneuver bit should be 2 to a 3 to
c5 a little bit exotic I think it's ok
d6 is a backwards pawn kind of but easy
to defend at some point I mean g2 could
be a target rook teach you yeah it's
Bishop f4 f5 so he's going for this so
do I take on e4 I mean if I take an e4
he takes takes takes my rooks attacks I
have five probably I want to start with
this and use Bishop f3 first of all my
bishops not getting trapped I don't
think unless he has before but then I
take okay let's do this another sub from
quacks thanks for subbing bishop a3 if
f5 it's okay now g2 is very well
defended okay so this bishop maneuver
has happened my bishop will come back to
life once it lands in c5
he's gonna put the King on you too
I should probably put thinking on you
seven and this could be a grind I mean
white might have a slight edge just more
space I do have the bishop hair could
trade if I want f5 make any sense we
trade it takes and then I five help me
not also have a five maybe a five does
you want to play e5 wants to play e5
maybe I should start with some rook move
I don't think that's a threat let's
start with a five if a five I think we
trade bishops we could trade Bishop for
a night even over up gg8 at some points
so g3 is normal
maybe rook a eight preparing a for you
might play for then I played rook a 646
Bishop h5 can be kind of annoying but
then he for his loose rook rook h6 is
interesting h4 rook back g4 and why
twins connect for what if I do this and
B for maybe B 5 B 5 is interesting be 5
we trade and I win a rook or the
exchange and then he has a 5 at some
points wait B 5 B 5 maybe e5 it's
confusing
v5 e 5 takes takes take there maybe take
first
really want to play b5 just not sure
about you five can take sticks now I
could take twice play King c6 I'll start
with this
I don't want my time to be ticking for
so long b5 still interesting B 5 B 5
what is this I take oh I could just take
on c4 first but then he takes with check
he's gonna win connect 4 but he's kind
of committing his pawns b v e5 we trade
on f3 takes King does h5 do anything
doesn't seem like it I can move back
but since still a five okay let's move
back with the rook rook doesn't belong
on the Kings side anymore spent too much
time there
my d-force probably maybe coming and I
could trade a four a three actually
probably I won't trade down the minute
on the clock
hands are cold it's cold outside these
are not sweating a for interesting I
probably just have to sit tight and
weights or what else to do maybe throw
and be six at some points each five it
is a move to consider someday f5 if I
could be interesting to actually some
pawn sack ie three play this just want
to equalize on time I might have some
idea playing f5 very soon
it looks unnecessary also risky I put
both rooks like on b6 and b4 and target
b3 might not be a bad idea
got the other work on d8 maybe now soon
f5 and he can take
just have to kind of wait around I'm up
on time again that's good
g5 so push takes takes takes takes tics
probably not good g5 is a good move
u5 to set to anything
probably not I don't really want to take
play maybe h6h six is actually really
interesting let's play h6 not much time
I did I miss my g4 maybe I can take
first and then play rook h8 yeah if he
takes on h6 I take the knight and then
play broke h8 so he doesn't have Knight
g4 you can play Knight g4 right away and
then we trade on g5 he might have not
have 6 at some points oh do I take first
with this is actually a problem I could
play f5 maybe this is a big problem
so takes takes I could sack I think I'm
gonna sack my bishop will control g1 and
there's some compensation I have a clump
of pawns but as hpn becomes past
so maybe Rick h8 expecting Knight takes
h6
now this isn't good okay going through
this line almost to do the H pawn could
just kill me I mean II 5f5 ideas
let's bring my king to be very careful
with my King though maybe e5 first so
setting up the possibility of f5 because
f5 e for it could be a very nice idea
ie or f5 now a5 my play rook e1 so maybe
here first and then f5 because I'm I
have e4
how does he defend for assuming he can't
make progress at the pawn I might have
some chances here but it's getting very
messy promise I'm down material so he
could sack that material but there's
hope and he's thinking time is getting
low rook t5 wow so it takes probably a
good practical move have to go for this
probably this to bring my king in
problem is the bishops gonna land on e4
it's going to be very unpleasant or the
King's gonna land on e4 maybe I could
play this first preventing h7 I think my
bishop could get to attack the pawn like
get to f8 there's still some interest
interesting I'd use a six sacking horn
you get some Bishop to e4 now I do have
F you know I don't have that three right
away
I have to be very careful with how I
manage this play this first I'll play f3
f2 it's gonna play like a rook each to
maybe cut the bishop on g3 if he lets me
she's not a bad idea that's a good move
let's play this 45 I have to mmm King
say now it's but they don't have time
for bits this is a very difficult
position
I want to play f3 at some point maybe
now it's a problem though you know
there's obstacle our bishops maybe my
King can get to h8 that's actually a
very nice idea put the King on h8 there
we go I feel slightly safer and I'm not
out of the water yet and this stuff
you'd be six I use rook c6 though
but then this move I'm tiny rock out for
you might miss Rekha for also finding
Bishop c5 defending everything okay one
play efore
time Scramble should just I mean looks
draws but I mean wait slightly better
sacking the pond looks very iffy I mean
it's just torture at this point
just trying to hold on and playing on
time really uh he's meeting me Gigi that
was rough
well this score is tied one and a half
to one and a half that's sad
but he played well well rematch did that
work
hey it works oh no I'm getting a call uh
decline okay good luck
am i playing another London also did my
camera died what just happened there
I think my camera is just dead is the
audio working
I hope the audio is working okay give me
one moment
FaceTime okay
you
well there goes my camera let's add a
new video capture my camera is literally
not working and it's playing b6 it was B
6 wait now I have to remember yeah this
game will be played without a camera
because I don't know what's going on
b6 it's a 95 right away maybe 95 right
away and like f4 takes takes this looks
reasonable I think I apologize that
there's no camera gonna remove this from
movie yes
wow so he's allowing this he's gonna
play 94 though okay 94 I could have to
focus first or two I do I could consider
queen g4 when g4 is interesting Knight
takes you to King takes t2 she looks
very interesting Kings kind it in the
center centers closed
I mean Queen g4 if he plays f5 I take it
takes takes let's play queen g4 I'll try
one more time with the camera otherwise
I'll try and figure it out between games
no it's like I don't know what's going
on it's kind of just dead okay I could
give myself like a like a picture or
something but you guys know what I look
like so it's fine okay so I play Queen
g4 allowing this line with King jigs d2
so I'm not castling of all of this game
but the center is closed I have some
attack I would draw stuff if I had
arrows I mean the main plan I think is
Bishop f4 Bishop h6 provoke g6 and then
play h4 h5 you might throw in like f6 or
f5
at some point I might play rook af1 and
then just run into the corner with my
king yeah this is reasonable for black
we're gonna do some trading
so it's imbalanced it's an interesting
position big question if black actually
wants to move the F falling which he
does now it's a question do I take on
Besant's probably not inclined to play
rook AF one let's play you're okay f1
I'm gonna put my phone on Do Not Disturb
so I don't get any more calls there
might be some idea of g4 like g4 we
trade and then like g6 is harga g7 can
be targeted
a five so you'll also play Bishop a six
so I should probably calculate G for
Bishop a six we trade in Brooklyn's on a
six I take on a five he takes Queen G
for takes takes I mean let's just do it
don't see anything like glaringly wrong
with it I mean he oh he has g5 though g5
then f5 or f4 but then I have h4 ideas
let's do it so Bishop a six so the
initial plan was to take take and queen
g4 my rooks are a bit disconnected this
could be Josh let's go for this look
safe
oh he's queen g5 or rook g5 at some
points but that should be okay if rook
g5 Queen takes you six talking about
this position if Queen g5 I have to take
my rooks are better coordinated than his
and I'm threatening to take on a five so
Baca needs to defend somehow Queen I
fates playable it takes on f1 I'm very
happy wait takes on that floor and I
don't think I can take on e6 because
rook f7 but meet me I can like takes on
f1 Queen Daisy 6 / got7 wreck f1 Queen I
Fayette takes takes Queen see a queen f8
takes so he's going for this line I have
to take
yeah Ezra it's gonna come back I could
start with you wreck have to start with
maybe like a four no should probably
play rock f2
this should be very draws thinking about
like walking Mikey whoa that looks wrong
because I got a defended passer maybe
it's playable of it takes takes it's
gonna play g6 so King can also maybe
push immediately is interesting I feel
like I should take take provoke g6 play
h4 I also just play rock f1 let's take
you six no King III makes the most sense
oh I have ideas of c4 like c4 ch sac
upon and then have to connected Center
pawns that could be very interesting
black has to be careful here I should
have considered c4 right away actually I
can still consider c4 he might have King
e6 though my time may have passed but
then we trade my rook activates probably
behind
see four takes d5 b5 king d4 that's
gotta be fun know if it's good that
looks fun let's do it I'm sacking upon
for two Center pawns please work
I think you have to play okay has to
take your play King e6 I'm expecting
King e6 another sub from uncle uncle
i'll Dratch thanks for subbing if you're
just joining I had issues with my webcam
do I played maybe rook you're a cure
first looks a bit more flexible because
I mean if he takes unhappy I have ideas
of c5 so ideas of taking activating the
rook the King Kings a black hater but
it's not a great luck hater if I can
check from behind deatha picks
there's no dark mode on just 24 as far
as I know I was trying to figure that
out earlier but had no success
okay I'm gonna focus on the game at
least try to he's gonna play rook d7 so
what to do g7 have to go for this I have
two Castor's against the King side
majority
became g3 then f4
I could start media with like this
attack the pawn and then if if g6 I play
rook f6 kind of sneaking around
attacking b6 and black actually might
get stuck at some points imagining g6
rook f6 B 5 and then king d3 and it's a
question how I make progress
I mean what else is black thinking about
maybe Brooke c7 but then I just take on
that v King c4 is a move you can see for
I probably just win that move I forgot
about I have rook b6 so this just went
upon how does he defend I don't think b6
can be defended if I wouldn't be six and
it's just happiness it's weird because I
didn't even consider King e6 but that
King e6 was probably not a move to play
because now I can take up a pawn g5 has
to go for something I could force a
trade I can win another pawn it's check
first King c4 is likely okay this I'm
very happy now this should be relatively
easy win assuming I don't mess up okay
six coming so the c4 move earlier really
transform the position nicely centered
pawns are surviving and thriving okay so
check probably just check I mean that's
just check I could trade and then play a
485
just making sure the lines work I mean
there's a few different ways to try and
win this but now this should just be
winning before it takes takes for you
mirror there wait a minute
it takes takes there and I have a five
key move okay
just double-checking King pawn undoing
my pawns are kind of separated three on
one on the Kings side it's not enough
for black if f4 I probably play kingi
for he plays h4 let's probably play a
five it's important to have be four at
the right moments okay probably king f4
now
not falling into anything tricky I hope
g3i just take it there there okay yeah
like my king is close enough it was an
attempt to break through okay I won a
game it's two and a half to one and a
half
I might restart the stream actually it
gives me one moment me to restart my
stream okay this will hopefully be very
quick I'm gonna like restart OBS and
then hopefully the webcam will be back
I'll see you guys in a few seconds